to us all of us to put our country back
together to heal this country and then
to build something even greater I
believe we can do this together
and that is why today I am ending my
campaign and endorsing Joe Biden when
the SOTA senator Amy Klobuchar survived
longer as a presidential candidate than
most of her Democratic rivals yesterday
she joined two of them former mayor Pete
Budaj and former Congressman Beto
O'Rourke in backing former Vice
President Biden their endorsement came
just hours before today's Super Tuesday
vote senator Klobuchar thanks for being
here you you came all the way from
Dallas over here you go I wanted to be
here and you're still smiling exactly
what we were proud of our campaign we
stuck together from the beginning from
the moment I announced in the blizzard
and as I said last night
well I'm ending my campaign I can't
think of a better way to end it than
joining Vice President Biden why did you
drop out just before Super Tuesday I
step back after South Carolina and we
were going to win Minnesota we had our
poll several public ones and I knew that
but then I thought what is our path and
what is really important to me and
what's really important to me is beating
Donald Trump and well I would have loved
to be that candidate I think Joe Biden
is going to be a great president I think
he's gonna bring decency back and
dignity to the White House which for me
is the number-one priority for this
country what goes into your decision
making process senator because in the
morning you were in for Super Tuesday by
afternoon you were dropped out I would
imagine this is painful for you you've
worked hard your team has worked hard
how do you begin to make this decision
and how do you process it now well for
me it was through the weekend I was at
the church in Selma and I was sitting
there you have some moment to think cuz
on the campaign trail you're going from
speech to speech and you don't have that
moment to reflect and I had that weekend
to reflect and I thought this is the
best thing and my husband actually kind
of wanted to keep going and I said I
think we can do good this way and what's
best for the country I just don't think
that the rule of law can handle four
more years of a
who thinks he's above it well I don't
think our democracy can handle former
years of a president who bulldoze us
through it and Joe Biden is the answer
is that is it President Trump that
you're worried about or is it Bernie
Sanders and I asked because Bernie
Sanders at a rally last night he said
look the establishment is getting
nervous corporate America is getting
nervous people like yourself are getting
nervous I know you'll say I'm not the
establishment hello Estelle ever but you
are you are a longtime senator yeah are
you nervous about a Sanders campaign you
know I think first of all what was cool
about last night is you have
mayor Pete and you have Beto or Rourke
who electrified Texas in his Senate race
and myself and I just don't think we are
the face of the establishment I think
we're fresh faces in our party oh you
know I think that I'm friends of Bernie
we came in together but as I said many
times on the debate stage I don't think
we should have a socialist heading up
our ticket and I think we have to have
someone as one prominent Democrat said
who is actually listening to where the
American people are that prominent
Democrat was Barack Obama he said it a
few months ago that we should pay
attention to where they are I don't
think they want to kick 149 million
Americans off their current health
insurance that standard so senator seems
to be real he has seems to be holding no
because he has but he has arguably the
most enthusiastic supporters the biggest
rallies right he has a lot of people
he's brought with him and my hope
because I saw what happened in 2018
where the most progressive people in our
party joined together with moderates and
independents and moderate Republicans we
all joined together to support
candidates for the house that's how we
turned the House of Representatives into
the people's house that's how they
passed gun safety legislation climate
change that's how they finally did
something when it comes to gun safety
all those bills are sitting on Mitch
McConnell's desk so I see this as part
of the March that started the day after
the inauguration and I see Joe Biden as
a candidate that can lead that mark Joe
Biden to Joe Biden promise you anything
I know not at all in the administration
never any discussion of it no nothing
you want to be right called and said I
want to go by JP I just ended my own
campaign and I am more than happy to go
back to
Minnesota today to thank our incredible
staff and the people of my state and
that's my plan I've got a day job
I love the Senate and I'm also going to
be does it go by the question do you
want to be Joe Biden yeah sure I never
look at hypotheticals they're gonna let
go and I did you consider endorsing
Michael Bloomberg did you consider
endorsing Bernie Sanders um you know
these are all friends I was honored to
be on the debate stage with them I'm not
someone that looks for the bad in people
I try to look for the good and my goal
is to bring everyone together by the end
of this what role do you think Michael
Bloomberg plays now what do you think is
at stake for him tonight because he's
based everything so far on Super Tuesday
he's gonna have to decide because he has
a lot of money into these states I know
the feeling of being a candidate when
you go on a show like this and then
there's more Michael Bloomberg ads than
there are you're there is your time on
the stage so I think he's gonna have to
decide we'll see what the results are
he's a good monster had an excellent
hands to you yes I I'm not gonna do an
exit dance all right senator klobuchar
thank you